well illuminati you know in the hip-hop
world illuminati meant like the new
world order it was about me
losing my life but before i lost my life
nuke dog was he would talk about having
conversations with the devil and how he
sold his soul snoop dogg i didn't cut a
deal with the devil suge knight took
shahada
this is what he told us we actually
became really really good friends two of
his sons took shahada
different kind of entanglement
as we know now as muslim the jinns do
these things that it would take her and
she would be it would take there's some
guy somewhere saying yeah i'm we're
friends no that's not true also there's
a thing that comes up every single
ramadan that i hate
[Music]
better known as napoleon is an american
former rapper of tupac's rap crew the
outlaws he spent a good portion of his
life making hip hop videos rapping and
singing with some of the most famous
people out there in the world living
more of a materialistic get me to bling
bing and everything that goes with that
lifestyle to searching for more meaning
in life purpose in life which led him to
where he is today in islam on the dean
show and now as a motivational speaker
helping others change their lives for
the better let's bring them on our
special guest muta aka
napoleon assalam alaikum salaam alaikum
salaam what i'm going to tell you
what's going on brother no stranger to
the show my good friend how has it been
how's it been
it's good man it's been a minute it's
been a minute man we haven't spoke i was
one of the first i'm the og on the
dean's show bro
yeah
too long i think it's a minute though
now it's been too long we can't let that
happen going forward man we got to keep
the connection stronger for sure
yeah
so sure brother i think it's been over
10 years if i'm not mistaken subhanallah
and i like what you said one of the
original ogs on the dean's show
[Laughter]
now being with the
outlaws you spent i mean a great portion
of your life
rapping making hip-hop videos a good
portion of your life with tupac so you'd
be the man to know there was this there
was this
this documentary that came out i think
it was not too long ago and i just
started looking into some of the some of
your old interviews and you know some of
these stories are interesting and it's
unfortunate many youth they still go and
they you know idolize some of the people
that you used to be around so inshallah
we can touch upon these things and shift
it to more of a positive message to more
of the lifestyle uh that you transition
to but tell me is there any truth to
this documentary of assassination have
you heard this documentary you probably
watched it i haven't watched it i think
i heard about it you know what i mean
but i haven't got a chance to check it
out
so the documentaries then we come
straight to the store the documentary is
saying that they finally solved the
murder of tupac is that true
well you know the streets and those who
who was around park we kind of really
know what happened you know what i mean
so
it wasn't really nothing to you know if
they solve it from a you know from uh uh
from a clinton criminal aspect you know
and they press charges on on someone
that's different but as far as the
streets as far as those who was around
park as far as those who was around
death row we know what happened you know
what i mean so
um and there's a chance that the people
that was involved in the majority of
them not even alive anymore oh okay so
nobody was ever arrested
nobody no one was ever arrested for the
for the murder pot
you know was it was what was interesting
when you were in one of your interviews
you were describing
the
last moments
of tupac after he got shot he was trying
to jump in the back seat suge knight is
over there uh trying to grab him saying
get down and he was cracking jokes all
the way to the hospital until finally
taking that last breath and saying i
don't think i'm gonna make it this time
yeah this is you know um after pot got
shot myself and the rest of the outlaws
we immediately went to las vegas from
los angeles and um
we put the like a bunch of guns in the
trunk and we drove out there we didn't
know what to expect so when pop passed
away um suge wanted to meet with us you
know myself and the rest of the outdoors
we met him and he wanted us to travel
back in l.a with him on his private
plane so when we first met him we met
him on like a a i forget if we i don't
know if he was like in some type of
convention hall it was in a hotel but we
went to a level a certain floor and it
was empty and we went into some room
like a convention room or something like
that and that's when he started
explaining to us what happened he lift
up his shirt and he had stitches in his
chest he had stitches in his head and he
started explaining what happened he said
you know when park you know got shot and
he you know he was joking all the way to
the hospital until and he took a deep
breath and was like i don't think i'm
gonna make it this time
and suge also said that when the shots
first you know you know start ringing
off pop tried to jump in the back seat
and shook said that he was the one that
told pop to get down and he grabbed him
and
and things like that because only shook
pock and and those who was involved in a
shooting really seen um you know what
really happened so the only word we can
take forward is sugar night work you
know what i mean he's the only one that
survived pretty much it was only him and
park in that car
now in that world of jahalia meaning the
days of ignorance where you don't know
what's coming next and now you compare
now you compare it now
you know where you know the details like
night and day
can you go ahead and reflect like your
situation your state of mind at that
time to now when someone says i don't
think i'm gonna be gonna make it any
further now
you're the way of life you're upon now
are the details all laid out the roadmap
from what comes
at that moment and beyond
you know now thank god thank god that he
guided us to the religion of islam
because we know that this life is
temporarily temporary on this earth and
we know that the next life is forever
you know but when we was in that mind
state you know before i was a muslim and
when you were in a mind state of you
believed that you know
i remember myself i used to always make
excuses and say that god would forgive
me no matter what because i come from
the ghetto and i used to say to myself
god will forgive me if i'm a wild person
if i do this and i do that but when you
accept the religion of islam you realize
that life doesn't work that way there
will be accountability
you know what i mean so it's scary when
you think back and i look back at it and
have a lot of friends who you know who
who passed away before they was able to
accept or even learn about the religion
of islam or you know or maybe islam
didn't come to them we hope that a lot
give them another chance on um yom
kiyama but it's scary the way the
mindset of many of the people walking
around heedless
you know we you know because i can i was
in i was in that situation at one
particular time with i was walking
around heedless you know i used to think
that no matter what i do
i can live my life the way i live my
life when i'm dead god will forgive me
that that was my mindset you know what i
mean
i haven't talked and touched upon this
kind of topic in a while but it's always
interesting you know for people who've
been there you know and then people are
still fascinated with it but uh remind
me again what is this term
illuminate what does this actually mean
well illuminati you know in the hip-hop
world illuminati meant like the new
world order
and you know park did a song called
killuminati i mean kill that noise
basically kill illuminati and all this
secret society that they doing this and
they're gonna do that you know what i
mean but um i look back at it from the
music industry
now and i wouldn't be surprised if
it's full of that you know what i mean i
wouldn't be surprised if you got people
doing somehow the magic i wouldn't be
surprised because you know when i was
involved in it when i met poc i think i
was 14 15 years old i was i was around
him up until he passed away and i
continue to do music
and um it's a very evil corrupt industry
very evil corrupt industry you know what
i mean and a lot of time the artists may
not even know that they might be doing
the work of these evil individuals
unknowingly
you know what i mean if you look at the
music that the people putting out
if you look at the type of stuff that
the type of music that the music
industry is spending million dollars to
promote it's all it it's all to excite
incite violence you know what i mean
nowadays you got so many young kids
killing each other rappers and where's
the people from the music industry i
mean you know the executives that's
making millions of dollars where are
they at they're not coming into the
ghettos they're not opening up youth
centers they're not coming trying to get
peace treaties they're not spending
money in these hoods but they're making
money off these these these environments
and in the inner cities and
and and making money off of rappers
killing each other
unfortunately you talk about how many of
these rappers that you know they would
they would tell stories uh how they were
aided by these devils by the shayateen
for sure for sure you know what bruh
well i brother eddie man i remember um
when i used to write my raps now that
i'm a muslim i know
unfortunately
what i was doing you know what i mean
but back then i didn't know i remember
when i used to write my raps i would i
would get drunk
you know i would drink and i would turn
the light off in the studio and i would
sit there and i would go into this stage
or the state of mind where i used to say
to myself
when the people listen to my lyrics i
want them to think the devil himself
wrote it so i used to try to bring
something out of me i swear by a lie i
used to say how can i sound like the
most evil person and i would drink and i
would drink and i would feel that
something was motivating me to say these
evil words and helping me put these
lyrics together now we know of course
it's the shea tin and his helpers you
know what i mean but
i went through that stage so i think a
lot of rappers go through that and maybe
unknowingly not know that they made a
pact with the shaytan mm-hmm wow you
tell me that i is it scary listening to
that because there's people out there
doing that right now what you're saying
and go
and doing some more devious just
uh evil things it's crazy yes
you mentioned this snoop dogg uh this is
firsthand you you knew that snoop dogg
was he would talk about having
conversations with the devil and how he
sold his soul snoop dogg himself you
know no you know the thing that people
mentioned about snoop dogg he did a rap
song so when i always say that the
people do it unknowingly like snoop had
a song
and in the song he sold his soul to the
devil he has a conversation going in the
song he has a conversation where he
going back and forth with the devil so
you know once i became muslim and i
start reflecting on these things i said
a lot of people because if the devil
comes to you straight up and say sell
your soul you ain't going to sell your
soul you know what i mean most of the
time but he's going to trick us in and
deceive us to make us think that we're
doing something that we can call hip-hop
so when you think about it that you know
when he did this song and he talked
about selling this so ain't no telling
what levels
of of involvement that the devil was
involved with maybe he don't know you
know what i mean maybe he didn't know
back then and this is why i say a lot of
time these rappers they do these things
unwillingly they do these things
unwillingly and um unknowingly i mean
not unwillingly unknowingly they do
these things unknowingly but they don't
know how far or how deep they really
take in a soul you know what i mean they
don't really know
have you had a chance to sit and talk
with snoop dogg to share with him
the meaning of life the purpose of life
i haven't you know it would be my
i would love to you know what i mean i
haven't i haven't spoken to snoop and
about i would say
um
you know i had a brief facetime call
with him about eight nine years ago uh i
would love to sit down and be able to
talk to if i can get back in touch with
many of the people that's in the music
industry and sit down and explain to
them man i feel like that's our duty
that's what i mean i feel like it's our
duty and and when even when i mention
these things about snoop it's not to put
them down because we did a lot of stuff
unknowingly we need guidance our people
need guidance and um so it's not an
attack on them we i would love to sit
down with them and and others in the
music industry and explain to them like
look man it's all
you know the life that we was living it
ain't what we think it is you know what
i mean submit to god no one's perfect
we're not telling you to accept the
religion of islam and you have to be
perfect because there's no perfect
muslim but at least if you have that
relationship with your lord and you you
worshipping your creator alone you know
what i mean that's you know you have
something to stand on on the day of
judgment
uh you heard it stoop dog we're trying
to get a message to you send a message
from
former aka napoleon muta
and let's hook you guys back up and
everything that you explained i remember
you telling me i think it was you who
told me that when you explained
everything about islam the oneness of of
god almighty the pure monotheism you
know the tenets of islam the theology
everything just made sense you know to
one individual who was kind of like the
mastermind behind many of these uh
record label the the one of the top
record labels should knight and he was
like
yeah
yeah sure you know a lot of is suge told
us myself
and i was with two saudi brothers
and he told us in his face that he be he
took shahada before he told me this suge
knight took shahadah
this is what he told us but of course
when he went through his trial i see him
win a cross so you know because
it's not good it's not good enough just
to take shahada we have to implement the
shahada we have to know what we're
saying so but he did tell us he said
that he took shahada before he said he
even fasted for ramadan when he was in
college he said these things you know
but we pray that a lot guide him back to
the truth open his chest um but two of
his sons suge knight jr and his other
son two of his sons took shahada
alhamdulillah you might have some some
people out there right now they're like
what's the shahada i want to take it
like what does that mean
the shahada is the declaration of faith
to enter the religion of islam it's a
belief that we utter with our mouth and
we believe in our heart it's a statement
that we utter with our mouths and we
believe in our heart that
there is no deity worthy worship except
allah alone and that muhammad is his
final messenger and that we accept the
religion of islam and we accept all the
prophets and messengers that came before
muhammad and not only after you know
once a lot of people think that once we
say the shahada that's it no
we have to implement our shahadah you
know we have to learn our religion of
islam and i think that's why we we see
these cases we know guidance is from
allah may allah give us all guidance and
don't let none of us go astray but we
have a lot where you see people take
shahada and then they fall off because
maybe they haven't tried to learn what
the shahada is or implement it and we we
need to start you know hopefully i'm
probably one of the guys that i can say
guilty with you know giving people
shahada and really don't really follow
up like that so it's important that we
need to follow up when these people
accept the religion of islam
going back to the
unseen world you talk about illuminate
continue on from there you mentioned a
story of a lady and she was
experimenting with different religions
and she was experimenting with wicca and
then she also uh she was dating someone
from the dog pound or something like
that can you elaborate on that story
well i remember that story but it was a
it was a female
um
like home girl of ours
and wow this story it is let me let me
recollect exactly what happened i
remember she said something where she
would do um
she would do she would play she was
following the wicked religion
pretty much a a satanism you know
and she was saying that she would be
able to her body
as we know now that's muslim the jinns
do these things that it would take her
and she would be it would take her to
the house of a friend of house of hers
and she would tell a girl the girl
everything she was doing like you know i
just saw you doing this and i saw you
doing that and her home girls would be
freaking out like girl are you spying on
me she said she broke down and started
crying and she said the only religion
that she after that the only religion
that she studied that made sense to her
was the religion of islam you know what
i mean i forget the home girl name but
um that's crazy bro you put back the
memories yeah we know these things
happen you know what i mean so now that
you're in islam submission to the
creator not the creation
now that you're on the way of jesus
moses abraham the last the final message
probably muhammad this is just a natural
way you know it makes sense it's a part
of your innate nature to believe this
and to live it it's a natural way like
you know
for anybody who's sincere open-minded
humblehearted now that you connect all
these things and you look back to your
previous life
and you start to look and we start
talking about the gin and this you know
these devils and and you make these you
can see these connections you know what
do you
uh think when you look back
you know when i look back at it
it's a sad situation because as i
mentioned
many of the people in that industry and
i i'm speaking from when i was involved
in that industry many of the people just
involved and and evil unknowingly
you know what i mean it's just the way
that
music nowadays it promotes and you can't
really blame the artist because a lot of
times we only want to blame the artist
but we forget that there's a machine
behind it
that's pumping music that's making
people be become violent you know what i
mean that make and don't get me wrong i
believe artists need to have some
accountability but when you got people
that's pumping millions of dollars
behind a lifestyle and it and they
telling you and they teach you that the
more of that lifestyle that you promote
the more that you dictate that lifestyle
to your audience the more money we're
gonna give you
and it's very difficult for an
individual to think that they're doing
something wrong
you know what i mean because they making
millions of dollars and they saying
people in the in the crowd screaming at
lyrics
and they never sit back and reflect
about the harm that comes with this
music many of them never do this you
know what i mean they never sit back and
they real and think about wait a minute
maybe we need to be held accountable for
what we was doing we need to be hold
held accountable for the lyrics we're
putting out there you know because you
might have blood on your hand
you know what i mean subhanallah tell me
so do you guys also you obviously get
the new the news that happens here
you're hearing it over there right the
things that are in the media
same thing over here you guys are
hearing over there right
of course yeah especially me you know
being in contact and with people from
back home it's sad bro it seemed like a
rap artist now is one of the most risky
jobs in america yeah the most dangerous
job
uh tell me i did you ever get in close
proximity did you ever meet
will smith
[Music]
you know what it is
wow okay all right okay so for get close
to anybody that was in his inner circle
i know charlie mack who's
he's one of the best friends will smith
best friend alhamdulillah charlie mac is
muslim um of course we met jada pinking
because she had a very good strong
friendship with tupac and also tupac
mother i never met will smith personally
how do you think would he end up
benefiting like with his situation
what do you think with what just
happened with uh chris rock
it's javascript that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh
richard
oh wow
wow
will smith is smacked out of me
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i jane jones keep my
wife's
i'm going to okay
i was sickened i was sickened by the
standing ovation
i felt like hollywood is just spineless
on mass
and uh it just
it really felt like oh this is a really
clear indication that uh we're not the
cool club anymore
man just you know it was sad to be
honest when i when i seen it and i read
about it and i even watched the video it
was actually a sad thing that you know
what i mean that it got to that point i
think he was it must be something else
in the inside that boiled to make him
want to react that way
it came out of nowhere because will has
something going on inside him that's
frustrated and i i i wish him the best
you know
you know a lot of celebrities have to
realize once you
become you on that world stage you you
were actually you you were you were
influenced on other kids
you're a role model to these kids
you're a role model to these kids so
when you reach a certain level you're
not 20 years old you're not 16 years old
you're old enough to have grandkids it's
very important that you behave in a way
that you want your kids to see or your
grandkids and your family to be proud of
you
you know what i mean and i think um i
think he he probably going to regret
what he done
i'm sure that he's going to realize that
he shouldn't have reacted in that manner
and um
you know what i mean because
especially the days that you live you're
living in a castle culture now where
they waiting for you to make any mistake
and they cancel you wow so will will
smith's uh what you said his best friend
what's his name charlie charlie mack is
one of the best best friends of will
smith and um and charlie mack is a
muslim he's muslim he's from philly he
muslim humbly he always be good at will
you know he's be good at will he's be
good if jada and uh and and he's a
person has wisdom so it's good to know
that we'll have some people someone like
that in this corner
because maybe he can give him some good
advice inshallah so we're that's what
we're hoping like in these situations uh
because so many things come up when
people don't have the blueprint for life
you know do you think now will smith
would be able to benefit not just in his
marriage i mean and just in totality his
whole life with islam
may allah give him his diet you know
what i mean i pray that i pray that he
accept the religion of islam because he
have like he have so many people that's
close to islam that i mean he has so
many muslims that are close to him you
know so you never know guidance is from
allah you never know he might realize
that islam is what he need to put some
order in his life you know what i mean
because money and fame doesn't
necessarily equal happiness
you know what i mean um
islam is what give that peace that you
you know cement to your creators what's
the only thing that's going to fulfill
that void that you feel in your heart
and uh so i pray that a lot may allah
guide him you know what i mean i pray he
get hidayah i mean i mean a lot of
things come up when you see this whole
situation you see rita
started a friendship with august
and
we actually became really really good
friends from there
you know as time went on i got into a
different kind of entanglement
no
yes
yes
yes
i don't believe so no
i guess what i'm saying is no okay good
me sitting down being honest i talk all
of my friends are men i don't have
female friends
i don't i'm incapable of that
why what do you mean well because you
know come on because you have a wife
well i have a wife and i don't i don't
really have female friends because look
okay let's get rid of this myth right
here okay i'm gonna tell you this let's
get rid of this right there that you're
an attractive woman there are some guys
somewhere saying yeah i'm we're friends
no that's not true
he's your friend only because you have
made it absolutely clear that nothing
else is happening except this friendship
we have
we remain your friends in hopes that one
day there'll be a crack in the door a
[ __ ] in the armor and trust and believe
that guy that you think is just your
buddy he will slide in that crack the
moment he gets the opportunity because
we're going to think this way
99.9
of us think that way
and you tell this to a woman and it just
blows her back no i have male friends
you have male friends because they know
it can be nothing else right now you
know this this comes to mind you know
with the whole situation
uh that protective jealousy that's there
outlined in islam
you know how how were you looking back
then at women compared to
now you know unfortunately
did you have this uh rita back then
bro i got latino blood in me i think
i think i always had this like this this
jealousy in miyake you know what i mean
um but islam teaches you how to have a
healthy jealousy you know what i mean a
healthy gear over your woman where it's
balanced
and islam surprisingly this practice is
it put everything in this in in this
dual place you know what i mean so but
back then i didn't really have respect
for women because i came from
environment that i remember as a kid if
i had a girl that i was i liked or
whatever and
you know i don't want to go into details
as soon as my homies see me with her i
would start acting all tough and
disrespectful towards them because the
environment showed us that the moral
respect you you might obtain is about
being disrespectful for women and then
when we went to the music industry we
kind of dragged that on with us you know
what i mean it wasn't really no respect
it just it just it was a very strange
upbringing you know uh i thank god that
i did come from a family of marriage i
knew my mother and father was married my
grandparents were married i had aunts
and uncle that married so i did see that
growing up you know what i mean but i
didn't have really no role model to
teach me how to treat a woman until i
accepted the religion of islam and i
started reading and learning and
studying how to profit how his
companions how they dealt with women
these were some of the most masculine
the most these are the people that broke
down roman armies the persian armies no
no army can come to them these was the
these was real men but yet they were so
patient and soft with dealing with a
woman
so we had it wrong all the time we
thought that in order to show us
to show that we are real men you got to
be tough to your woman and strong and
yell at them but we get from the prophet
in this companion is the opposite
uh we saw some videos with you with uh
fat was it fat joe
and him saying
saying some uh you know different words
like you know um
and it seems he sets off like like did
he accept islam is he close to it or
what's what's the situation with fat joe
is that his brother oh man
that's his proper name right that's his
proper name i don't want to feel like
that's what they call him
okay i don't want to i don't want to
offend nobody but that's what he that's
he's his name
okay okay so sorry
you know joe man he's a very like
genuine dude yeah a lot of people don't
know we we i have over 20 maybe maybe 25
um yeah relationship with fat joke
myself the outlaws do um our old manager
steve lobel
and when pop died there was a lot of
people in the music industry who we
thought was friends or pop as soon as he
died they turned their back on the
outlaws so that was the first time we
seen that the music industry is fake
that people that was laughing in pocket
saying we love you we got your little
homies as soon as he passed away they
turned on us fat joe was was a very rare
individual he reached out to us and he
was like man i don't know how these guys
claim they love pocket and you guys it's
homies and nobody's showing y'all love
so he was like man i want y'all to come
and be on my video i want you to come
open up in my shows in new york he he
used to bring us on a radio with him
when he come to l.a so he really showed
us a lot of love and not too long ago i
recently got back in contact with him
you know we even throughout the years he
would go to dubai and we have mutual
friends and he would send a message but
i would say about two three years ago i
was able to get back in contact with him
and speak with him in fact joe have a
lot of respect for islam
he goes to dubai often he rubbed
shoulders with muslims uh he says
as you know bismillah
i even seen an interview where i don't
even think he knew what he was saying he
was just talking and i heard him say
alhamdulillah so
may allah guide him you know i mean like
he's very close he seemed very close to
islam come come fat joe come come
uh yeah i mean a lot giving me diet and
you know i realized that eddie man you
know i was in puerto rico
about two three months ago because my
mother's side of the family is from
puerto rico and the last time i was
there was over 20 something years ago
this time i went back with a different
mindset i got in contact with my aunts
and my uncles that i never met before my
mother's older sister and i was able to
really spend time with locals there the
puerto rican people masha'allah they
soft-hearted in general
the island of puerto rico man if
somebody go there and start giving
strong dawah i think a lot of them would
be accepting the religion of islam they
just have this nature in them you know
what i mean where and they remind me of
the filipinos here in saudi arabia
the majority of the people that accept
the religion of islam from the
foreigners are filipinos they have
similar you know you know um
characteristics and mannerisms as latino
people yeah and these are smart
individuals i mean they're not stupid
like the will smiths you know the fat
joes the
uh the other people we're going to try
to get you hopefully get back in contact
with um
if they just took a little bit of
sincere time and devotion to studying
islam it wouldn't take long and asking
the creator of the heavens and earth
alone for guidance for them to see that
this is indeed the truth
true you know
what you just said is 100 correct if a
person really want guidance and they
truly ask god to guide them
allah will guide them insha'allah we
hope insha'allah but we gotta have that
we they have to start with themselves
you know what i mean
inshallah so just a few more questions
before we uh conclude tell me you see a
lot of people even when they retire from
let's say music they still want their
records to sell but you had a message
for everybody like listen just get rid
of my stuff i don't want you listening
to it
because you know
when i realize now man a lot of my
lyrics
it ain't called to nothing but good you
know don't get me i didn't call to good
i mean don't get a lot of them i said
don't get me wrong we did have we had
some lyrics where we tried our best to
put a positive message out there but the
overall message as allah says in the
quran about you know the wine the the
the the is good and it's benefiting but
the evil outweighs the good so refrain
from it all together so you're not going
to benefit from it you know what i mean
it's a lot of stuff that you know that
i'm embarrassed to listen if i listen to
it now i'm shocked that i used to be
behaved like that he just let me know
how how allah guided me
you know what i mean so i know i don't
have no control over it when i walked
away from the music industry i think a
lot that i walked away from everything i
don't make a penny off of it a lot of
people say to me well you telling people
not to listen to your music and you
talking bad but you still benefiting i
walked away from royalties i probably i
probably would have still been saying
millions of dollars right now but i
don't take a penny i don't feed my
family from no money from the music
industry i don't accept no money from
the music industry i just gave up on it
i left it by allah's guidance i knew
that it was better another way of life
and i walked away from it but the lyrics
that we put out majority of the time
back in the day it was it was negative
you know what i mean i wrote i don't i
don't think i ever wrote a rap song
sober
you know what i mean like i said i used
to try to whenever i used to write my
lyrics i used to want people to say when
they hear it i want them to think the
devil wrote it with me so of course i
don't want the kids to listen to these
things you know what i mean because you
know you are what you listen to you
start behaving you know music and hip
hop the the it's a culture that comes
with it
the majority of the people that listen
to it they start behaving like that and
you even see that in the muslim
countries
unfortunately i'm hearing saudi arabia
and i was sitting in my coffee shop and
you would see a person come in here and
say what's up my [ __ ] and he would
think that that's going to impress me
and i have to explain to these
youngsters you know what i mean i try my
best to do it with wisdom but they
listen to rap music and they think that
this lifestyle is going to bring them
some issues you know what i mean it was
going to bring them some type of honor
when and and and it should be the
opposite they should be able to look at
uh as they should be able to look at the
muslims and look at the muslims and say
i want to get some guidance from these
individuals it shouldn't be the it
shouldn't be the other way around
uh you often have a beautiful quote that
you repeat uh from one of the great
scholars uh how music is the quran of
the devil can you elaborate on that
yeah i think it was if i'm not mistaken
it'd been the best one of the scholars
he said the music is the shaytan of the
devil because
you know um
the music
most of the time is going to take even
if a person say for example when i only
listen to positive music there's no cuss
words but at the end of the day the
music is going to take over you're going
to be more inclined to music than listen
to the quran and i think one of the
sahaba also said that you will not find
a heart that can listen to music and
quran at the same time one of them will
overthrow the other one you know what i
mean so even if you're listening to
music i remember i read a study a long
time ago from toronto university where
they said listening to certain musical
instruments it affects a person
physically they said certain musical
instruments release the chemical
dopamine in the brain as if your person
is taking hardcore drugs such as cocaine
so imagine if you listen into something
because you want to feel good and you
listen into something because it can
affect your mood
you might end up replacing the quran you
might end up saying i don't need the
quran now and it might happen step by
step slowly but surely but you would end
up saying the quran is
which is a healing for the heart and
allah says the healing of the heart you
will end up probably thinking that music
is going to heal your heart because it's
releasing this dopamine dopamine give
you this good feeling and unfortunately
even it was another study where they
said music is also addictive like
cocaine
you know what i mean so as a muslim
nothing should dictate our our mood our
uh what it you know our mannerism our
happiness our our sadness um we sh we
shouldn't allow anything to do that you
know what i mean we should we should
rely on the quran um music would do that
you know what i mean i remember growing
up bro we had a music for everything we
wanted to do we had a song for example
we want to go you know meet up with
somebody and do something wrong we had a
song for that if we want to go do um
like some violence we put a certain song
on for that if we want to go just have a
chill night we put a song like that so
it becomes a music become a soundtrack
to the life of an individual
you know what i mean and unfortunately
a lot of people get misguided thinking
that music is something like but it's
not like even if even studies show that
it's very detrimental and it can be
harmful to a person physically so now
you could say that for
you
uh you've been able to just stay away
from
this for
i mean how long over a decade now uh
i'm alhamdulillah i would say
i've been muslim mashallah tabata kala
for 19 years now
i probably stopped listening to music
you know um
i would say for about 15 years it didn't
it wasn't easy you know
it didn't it didn't it didn't happen
overnight you know what i mean and and
um so it took some time definitely but
alhamdulillah i was able to stay away
from it and i realized even when i was
struggling with music i remember that
like it was yesterday
the days that i was listening to music i
would wake up feeling depressed for no
reason
i would just wake up and i'll be like
why am i feeling depressed and and when
i read about that study about music it
mentioned how it affects the mood
you know music will actually really
affect your mood so it will bring you
down it can bring you up so i realized
when i saw this that you know when i
stopped listening to music i stopped
feeling depressed i stopped feeling you
know the sadness you know for no reason
and there's nothing in islam that it
prescribes or tells you to stay away
from that there's not wisdom behind
the legislation so i mean look i mean
people talk about mental health issues
and all depression and all that but a
lot of people not linking it to this
true it has it has a major effect on it
you know it has a mate you know music
music has a major effect on the mental
health
a lot of people don't know that you know
what i mean it has a major effect
because you know music also
is connected to what especially hip-hop
music is connected to drugs it's
connected to a lifestyle you know what i
mean you're not going to see too many
people that's going to listen to rap and
all of a sudden he's sober
you know drugs bring mental health
issues
you know what i mean and drug and mental
health issues is rampant in the latino
and the african-american community we
we sweeping under the rug
you know what i mean we sweep it under
the rug and unfortunately we have to
address everything that leads to things
that's detrimental to our house
physically mentally you know what i mean
we have a lot that we pushing and
promoting and like i said the music
industry they have no
they have no
they have no um what can i say
they have no support
if you think about it these these the
music industry is a billion dollar
industry
you don't see columbia records you don't
see inter-school record you don't see
none of these record labels setting up
anything in the african american
communities wow supporting mental health
support and poverty they're making
billions of dollars and they're not
giving nothing back to the ghettos but
they're taking these artists from these
ghettos they don't give out health
insurance they don't they they
they don't help with nothing they just
take their money and then the rapper
stops selling records they kick them to
the curb and they bring someone else
it's sad you know what i mean it just
brought back some memories uh i i think
uh we were together also in canada right
it was it was a loon was it freeway
do you do you remember that yeah yeah
yeah
yeah did you have a good memory bro you
got it yeah but did you still stay in
touch with them for freeway with uh lulu
and how's it with some of the yeah i'm
in touch with them every every once in a
while freeway loon um alhamdulillah even
when noon was locked up i was in touch
um i was able to get in touch you know
with a good friend of mines to help him
help get lune out of prison you know i
had a good friend of mine as well then
angelos who who was locked up and they
tried to give him like 50-something
years in prison um
he's uh he was from utah you know i was
the one gave him shahada he accepted the
religion of islam his story was it was
crazy they tried to put him in prison
they actually gave him 55 years in
prison he fought he fought his sister
also fought and barack obama was able to
release him so when weapon angelos came
home the first thing he did he did 15
years in prison
and the first thing he did is he
contacted me said i want to help others
who are in prison who i feel like you
know wrongly convicted and you know he's
like can you give me some names and the
first name i gave him was loon
i said man get this help help try to get
this brother out so i always been in
touch with him from the time he was in
prison from the time he came home um
also freeway we talk every once in a
while so these my brothers for life
inshallah
we see some stars up there on the
ceiling uh this is uh your your
beautiful cafe people can yeah this is
just
that's just some light some decorating
light that we try to
to make the people feel like they're in
space
so this is a this is uh
you're in uh riyadh right
i'm in riyadh yes yes
oh so people can stop stop by and have a
coffee there with you
yeah come to mw cafe have a coffee you
know i'm also a partner with a
restaurant called smokey beers if you
want some strong you know we have some
albanian brothers some saudi partners
with us but our bandian brothers are tan
and um sunny and saudis from saudi we
put a team together and they came up and
opened up a smoked brisket restaurant
made from albanian american brothers
from dallas texas marshall come get the
real experience insha'allah beautiful
give us uh some uh closing comments and
advice ramadan's
here it's coming up uh what advice do
you have for for the people i would say
man ramadan is another chance for us to
get closer to allah another chance for
us to get our sins forgiven inshallah
and also there's a thing that comes up
every single ramadan that i hate
you know i know social media they start
doing these hashtags where they call
people ramadan muslims i think muslims
we should refrain from that because when
you see a person who never prayed before
never will he jab before never grew
their beard before um but you see them
in ramadan trying you see them praying
you see them you know taking that first
step that might be the first step for
them to continue so and rather instead
of calling them um instead of calling
them ramadan muslims it's best to
support these individuals to make dua
for these individuals and
refrain from that
you know i think it's very important to
refrain from that you know what i mean
it and and realize that ramadan is a
month for mercy so we should be showing
mercy to each other and we should take
advantage of it
definitely take advantage of us because
every single muslim on the earth we need
this month so may allah give it give us
two feet i mean thank you very much and
let's uh let's keep the connection and
inshallah
you come back uh to the states uh you
you visiting uh anytime soon
the states i got it i got to come back
and i would be in that late this summer
inshallah i haven't been in la man three
years
you know i have to get back there
inshallah all right inshallah we can
connect in person maybe uh in chicago
like before
and that was our
brother muta aka napoleon here on the
dean show
really nice talking with you my brother
and let's get this connection back with
him
and
snoop dogg
and will smith let's get this message
out because
we can give you all the ferraris someone
can give you all the ferraris all the
money in the world but you got all that
you know what i mean and those 10 those
gifts are what temporary you know you
can't take it when you go go where leave
this life right but the best gift that
we can give you
is
the purpose in life to give you islam
and inshallah fat joe
and all the others that we were talking
about and beyond just the layman you're
just the average person here you want to
know what the purpose of life you've
been listening to these rappers all day
and night and you are depressed and you
know you're sick of smoking the blunts
and drinking and
partying and you're like there's got to
be more to life yes there is and it's
the way of life that our brother mutah
is upon
that so many people now are coming to
know about and they're looking into it
and it's to gain that peace that we all
want to gain purpose by submitting your
will to the creator of the heavens and
earth and that's islam so go ahead and
get your freak i got to give for you a
free copy of the quran at the
deenshow.com if you have some questions
go ahead and also call us at
1-800-662-4752
get this message to these individuals so
we can help muta make the connection
with them again inshallah may god
almighty allah guide them and we see you
next time until then peace be with you
don't forget to support us on our
patreon and we'll see you next time
peace be with you assalamu alaikum and
if you liked this episode of the dean
show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum